[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا على ميسون واحد وهذه
العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل زواياه ومن
جميع جوانبهم نبدا بالعناوين
نوره
[موسيقى]
ده افغانستان يغتال احد ابرز قيادي طالبان
وامريكا تعتقد انه الخطر المقبل
[موسيقى]
وزير الدفاع الامريكيه في اسرائيل توافق
حول مواجهه ايران وخلاف على عنف مستوطنين
جورجيا تستذكر ايام ثورتها الملونه وحربها
مع روسيا موالونه لموسكو ومعارضون
والكرملين يرفع يده
ولدينا ايضا
الصين تطور جيشها بتكنولوجيا امريكيه رغم
العقوبات واشنطن تؤكد ان التهديد
الاستراتيجي اصبح وشيكا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قتل داود مزمل حاكم ولايه بلغ
شمال افغانستان بانفجار داخل مقر ادارته
في مدينه مسار شريف عاصمه الولايه واسفر
ايضا عن سقوط عدد من القتلى والمصابين قبل
قليل اعلن تنظيم داعش خراسان مسؤوليته عن
الحادث وهو تنظيم شنه هجمات متفرقه على
حركه طالبان خلال الاشهر الاخيره
داوود مسمل يعتبر احد كبار مسؤول طالبان
الذين يقتلون في مثل هذه الظروف منذ عوده
الحركه الى السلطه في اغسطس 2021
وتشير الانباء الى انه ربما كان عبد الغني
برادر نائب رئيس الوزراء المستهدفه
بالهجوم خاصه وانه زار ولايه بالخيا يوم
امس رفقه مسؤولين كبار اخرين للاشراف على
مشروع رين كبير في شمال افغانستان بحسب
بيان صدر عن الحكومه
دعونا مشاهدينا نتعرف معكم الان على
الهيكل التنظيمي لحركه طالبان في
افغانستان حيث يتولى هبه الله اخوان زاده
قياده التنظيم تولى زعامه الحركه منذ عام
1916 ويعد المرجع الاعلى للحركه في الامور
السياسيه والدينيه والعسكريه الرجل الثاني
في طالبان هو رئيس الوزراء محمد حسن اخوان
هو نائب رئيس الوزراء ابن فتره حكم حركه
طالبان الاولى بين عامي
و2001 ثم عاد ليراس حكومه طالبان في
السابع من سبتمبر 2021
سانتقل الان الى الشخصيه الثالثه في
القياده هو عبد الغني برادر وهو احد
المشاركين في تاسيس الحركه يشغل برادر
حاليا منصبه نائب رئيس وزراء حكومه
الطالبان ويعتقد انه كان في الانفجار الذي
وقع في مزار شريف شمال افغانستان سنواصل
الان مع الهيكل القيادي لطالبان لنصل مع
سراج الدين حقاني هو زعيم شبكه حقاني
وتولى لاحقا منصب وزير الداخليه في حكومه
طالبان ونيابه زعامه الحركه نائب اخر
لقائد الحركه هو محمد يعقوب وهو نجم مؤسس
الحركه الملا عمر ووزير الدفاع في حكومه
طالبان افغانستان
نعود الان لتنظيم داعش في افغانستان
ومناطق وجود التنظيم في افغانستان سنتابع
ونبدا مع التنظيم اين نشا هو نشا في ولايه
ننجرهار ثم بدا يتحرك تدريجيا الى ولايات
الشمال الافغاني وتحديدا في ولايات
بدغشان وتخار وقندوز وبالخ وبغلام
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه تشير الى ان داعش
خرسان ينتشر في هذه الولايات التي تحدثنا
عنها لضعف سيطره طالبان فيها كما ان له
وجود في العاصمه نذكر مشاهدينا هنا ان
حركه طالبان اعلنت قبل اسبوع قتل مسؤولين
التابعين لداعش في كابول خلال الايام
الماضيه احدهما مسؤول اقليمي والاخر قائد
الجناح العسكري اما عن عديد عناصر داعش
خرسان قدرت الامم المتحده اعدادهم بثلاثه
الاف مقاتل فيما تعتقد معاهده الامن
الجامعي انهم سته الاف مقاتل حركه طالبين
بدورها نشرت تقديرات تشير الى ان عدد
عناصر داعش خرسان يصل الى سبعه الاف عنصر
وبشكل عام تعتمد داعش خرسان في تسليحها
على الاسلحه المتوسطه وايضا الخفيفه
هذه التطورات مشاهدينا تاتي بعد يوم من
تحذير رئيس المخابرات الدفاعيه الامريكيه
للجنرال من ان التنظيم القاعده لا يشكل
تهديدا لامريكا في الوقت الحالي مشيرا الى
انه يحاول النجاه الا انه حذر من خطر داعش
في افغانستان
[موسيقى]
على معرفه ما يحدث في افغانستان منذ سقوط
الحكومه لكن لا تزال لدينا بعض القدره على
ذلك وبناء على ما نعرفه بشان تهديد
القاعده هم يحاولون النجاح ولا خطط لديهم
للهجوم على الغرب قريبا يعتقد ان تنظيم
داعش هناك يشكل تهديدا اكبر هم يتعرضون
للهجوم من نظام طالبان الان وهي مساله وقت
قبل ان يكون لديه القدره على مهاجمتنا
من دبي ينضم اليه وزير الداخليه الافغانيه
الاسبق محمد عمر داوود السيد السيد محمد
اهلا بكم معنا الى اي حد والى اي مدى داعش
خرسان اصبح يشكل تهديدا كبيرا في
افغانستان وخاصه بانه الان بدا يطال
القيادات في طالبان
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
كان
قد اصبح اكثر قوه على نحو متزايد والسبب
في ذلك هو انه قد تم اعتقال لاعداد كبيره
من افراده من قبل الحكومه السابقه وعندما
جاء الطالبا الى سده الحكم قامت باطلاق
سراح الالاف من السجناء والان باتوا بوضع
يسمح لهم بتجميع صفوفهم وشن هجوم على
طالبا لكن هناك اهداف اخرى تقومون
باستهدافها مثل المقدمي المعونات
الانسانيه وغيرهم وعلى هذا الاساس فان
طالبا تعد تهديدا كبيرا هل حقيقه يتواجد
داعش خرسان في الولايات التي تضعف فيها
سيطره طالبان
هذا صحيح على حد معلوماتي فانهم يعملون في
في كافه ارجاء البلاد
هو ثلاثه ثلاث مناطق اساسيه في الشمال
والشرق والغرب التي تعد موطن قوه طالبان
وهم بشكل اخر في كل مكان في افغانستان
وعمليه الهجوم التي طالت حاكم
الولايه الذي يعدهم احد كبار المسؤولين
الكبار في ولايه بلغ فان داعش خرسان تثبت
بانها قادره على شن هجوما في اي مكان وباي
وقت لماذا هذا التضارب باعداد داعش خرسان
في افغانستان يعني طالبان تتحدث عن سبعه
الاف الامم المتحده تتحدث عن 3000 بعض
المنظمات تتحدث عن 6000 الى اي مدى هناك
صعوبه بمعرفه اعدادهم ولماذا
لعل العدد الاصلي لمجموعه 11 خرسان قد
يكون بين اربعه الى خمسه الاف فرد لكن كل
يوم يقومون
بالوصول الى طالبان اذا افراد من طالبان
يتحولون الى ليصبحوا ضمن داعش وكذلك قد
يكون هو واقع الحال ولهذا السبب اخذ في
التزايد مع مرور الوقت بسبب وهذا هو سبب
وجود التضارب في التقارير لكن من المؤكد
ان عددهم بازدياد
سيد محمد بالنسبه ايضا لداعش خرسان اليس
هناك من تخوف بان يصبح هناك اتباع لطالبان
تابعين لداعش خرسان لان الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والماليه لدى طالبان اصبحت
ضعيفه جدا
ان المتابعين
ان متابعي داعش خرسان باتوا
يتزايدون فبعضهم كانوا قد انضموا من مناطق
اخرى ليس لاسباب ايديولوجيه بل لاسباب
اقتصاديه فان الفقر باتم منتشرا في كافه
الاماكن ولا يمكن لشخص
يتقاضم 100 دولار شخصيا ان يستمر في تلك
الظروف الاقتصاديه وهناك سببين ايضا التي
تعود لزياده اعداد داعش الاسباب
الاقتصاديه وثانيا بان ان طالب ان تقوموا
بتنحيه واستثناء كافه الاشخاص
الا منهم من ضمن دائرتهم المغلفه وهذا سبب
زياده جديه لدى طالبان بالقضاء على داعش
خرسان لان البعض يعتبر بانه من الممكن ان
تكون هناك ورقه ضغط تستخدمها طالبان على
الدول المجاوره وعلى الدول الاوروبيه حتى
تستطيع ان تاخذ
للاعتراف بها وايضا
لمساعدتها اقتصاديا
من المذكر ان نطلق احكاما بهذا الامر حتى
اللحظه فان النجاحي طالبان كان بالحد
الادنى
ولم يقوموا الا بقتل او اعتقال عدد كبير
من داعش خراسان وهناك شكوك بان طالبا لا
تقوموا بمحاربه داعش بصوره جده في الحقيقه
انهم يعملون على تخبئه اماكن وجودهم ولا
يقولون بانهم موجودين في المقام الاول
وعلى هذا الاساس فانهم لا يعملون على
محاربه قد يكون هذا هو الامر بانهم سوف
يستخدمونهم كورقه التفاوض شكرا لك
محمد عمر داوودي على المشاركه معنا في
العربيه 360
مشاهدينا نتابع هذه الصور الان من تل ابيب
حيث عمليه اطلاق النار في مقهى اسفرت عن
اصابه شخصين حتى الان ولا حديث حتى الان
حول تفاصيل الهجوم سواء كان جنائيا او له
دوافع سياسيه اذا هناك اصابه لشخصين في
اطلاق نار في مقهى في تل ابيب نتابع هذه
الصور ولكن ليس هناك اي تفاصيل حول اذا
كانت هذه العمليه الجنائيه ام دوافعها
سياسيه
وهذه الصور ايضا كانت وصلتنا قبل قليل
لعمليه اطلاق النار في تل ابيب ولكن حتى
الان ليس هناك اي تفاصيل الا اصابه شخصين
في اطلاق النار في هذا المقهى في تل ابيب
نستمع الى صوت الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
فرضت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبات على
ايران هي الثانيه خلال يومين وشماله
العقوبات الجديده 39 فردا وكيانا بما فيها
عقوبات ضد كيانات مقرها الصين وشركات تعمل
على تصنيع المسيرات ايضا هناك عقوبات على
شبكات مصرفيه تساهم بدخول مليارات
الدولارات على ايران سنويا بحسب ما اوردت
الوزاره
خلال زيارته لاسرائيل كذا وزير الدفاع
الامريكي ان امريكا ملتزمه بامن اسرائيل
في مواجهه الانشطه الايرانيه الا انه اكد
ان امريكا قلقه من عنف المستوطنين تجاه
الفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بامر اسرائيل
وسنستمر في ذلك الرئيس بايدن اكد خلال
زيارته لاسرائيل على قوه الروابط بين
شعبينا واسرائيل شريك مهم للولايات
المتحده نعمل مع اسرائيل وندعمها في ضمان
امنها كما نشعر بقلق بالغ من زياده ايران
لتخصيب اليورانيوم وتهديد امن المنطقه من
خلال دعمها للارهاب ونعمل على منعها من
امتلاك سلاح النووي كذلك الولايات المتحده
قلقه ايضا من عنف المستوطنين ضد
الفلسطينيين بشكل خاص
من جانبه شدد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتانياهو على ضروره تبني نهج حازم
ضد ايران وقال ان من يعتقد انه سيتم
تركه الى نووي هو مخطئ
[موسيقى]
لدينا اجنده مشتركه لمنع ايران من امتلاك
السلاح النووي والتصدي لاي عدوان قد تشنه
طهران للحفاظ على امن وازدهار المنطقه
والسعي لتوسيع دائره السلام
هذا اللقاء بين نتنياهو في المطار بسبب
الاحتياجات المناهضه لخطط رئيس وزراء
اسرائيل بتغيير النظام القضائي لينتهي
اليوم باعلان الحكومه عن عزل قائد شرطه تل
ابيب المتظاهرون احتشدوا امام
مطالبينجوريون وحاولوا منع نتنياهو من
السفر الى ايطاليا بعد ان التقى وزير
الدفاع الامريكي لكنه غادر في النهايه دون
ان يعلق على الوضع الامني الزميله لانا
كالغاسي كانت هناك وتبعت المشهد
[موسيقى]
نحن هنا نتواجد في مطار بن غريون الدولي
حيث يتواجد عشرات المتظاهرين الغاضبين
الذين يحاولون منع رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو من السفر الى
ايطاليا بسبب ما يعرف بتغيير نظام القضائي
وقاموا بعرقله حركه السير داخل شوارع
المطار بعد مراوغه قوات الامن التي سمحت
لهم بالدخول ظنا انهم من المسافرين لم
تعرقل هذه المظاهرات فقط رحله 60 الف
اسرائيلي سيسافرون من مطار بن غوريون
اليوم انما عرقلت زياره وزير الدفاع
الامريكي
مرتين الى اسرائيل حيث قرر اجراء اللقاءات
مع صانعي القرار قرب المطار دون الدخول
الى البلاد ومن المتوقع ان تستمر هذه
المظاهرات طالما ان الحكومه مستمره في
الانقلاب على القضاء لا نقول غاصي من مطار
بن غوريون العربيه
في العربيه 360 سنتابع بعض لحظات الصين
تحذر امريكا من استمرار التفكير بعقليه
الحرب البارده وتقارير تؤكد ان بكين سرقت
معلومات عسكريه خطيره من امريكا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان
السعوديه جاهزه للقيام بما يلزم لحل
الصراع في اوكرانيا وفي رده على سؤال
لمراسله العربيه اكد الامير فيصل بن فرحان
ان السعوديه تواصل العمل لانهاء النزاع
نسعى دائما لدعم كل ما من شانه
الوصول الى تسويه لهذا الصراع ونحن جاهزون
للعمل مع الاطراف
للبحث عن الحلول السلميه وقد سبق انساهمنا
فيما
حصل في من تبادل السجناء
والذي اشرف عليه سموه العهد مباشره بتعاون
مشكور من الجانب الروسي
فنستمر في البحث عن الفرص المتاحه
لتسهيل الحوار بين الطرفين
من جهاته قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيسور
العربيه ان موقف السعوديه من الازمه
الاوكرانيه ليس محدودا بتبادل الاسرى وان
موسكو تؤكد حرصها على التعاون مع السعوديه
في كل المجالات
تطرقنا لمناقشه عده قضايا في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا موسكو رياض متفقتان على ان
الحل السياسي هو الافضل لكل القضايا
العالميه بمشاركه جميع الاطراف نحن نقدر
عمل اصدقائنا في السعوديه والدور الذي
تلعبه المملكه في المنطقه
قالت المخابرات الامريكيه في تقرير السنوي
لتقييم التهديدات ان روسيا لا تريد صراعا
مباشرا مع الولايات المتحده والناتو لكن
ذلك قد يحدث واشارت المخابرات الامريكيه
الى ان روسيا غير قادره على الاستمرار في
حربها باوكرانيا من دون دعم عسكري من دول
اخرى
تتناقض تلك التصريحات مع ما قاله رئيس
المخابرات العسكريه الليتوانيه الذي اكد
ان روسيا لديها ما يكفي من موارد لمواصله
الحرب في اوكرانيا لعامين واشار الى ان
الموارد التي تمتلكها روسيا في الوقت
الحالي ستكون كافيه لمواصلات الحرب مضيفا
ان طول الفتره التي يمكن لروسيا ان تشن
فيها الحرب يعتمد ايضا على الدعم الذي
يتلقاه الجيش الروسي من دول مثل ايران
وكوريا الشماليه
[موسيقى]
تجددت التظاهرات في محيط البرلمان في
العاصمه الجورجيه تبليسيه رفضا لقانون
الوكلاء الاجانب المثير للجدل تجدد
التظاهرات جاء رغم اعلان الحكومه انها
ستسحب القانون الا ان المعارضه اكدت انها
ستواصل الحشد في الشارع ورفضت تصديق
الحكومه وكان التظاهرات الامس تحولت الى
اشتباكات بين المتظاهرين وقوه الامن
[موسيقى]
نشر الحزب الحاكم بيانا قال فيه انه مستعد
لالغاء مشروع القانون الروسي الذي اثار
الاحتجاجات في شوارع تبليسي لا نصدق هذا
البيان السياسيه لان لدينا تجربه حزينه
للغايه الحلم الجورجي كذب على الشعب عده
مرات نحن بحاجه الى طرح هذا القانون على
الجلسه البرلمانيه المكتمله والغائه بشكل
رسمي
رفضا لقانون الوكلاء الاجانب حيث يرى
المحتجون انه قانون برعايه روسيه ويجب
التصدي له مشروع القانون يطالب وسائل
الاعلام والمنظمات غير الحكوميه التي
تتلقى اكثر من عشرين بالمئه من تمويلها من
مصادر اجنبيه بالتسجيل بصفتها وكلاء نفوذ
اجنبي ويرى معارض القانون بانه مستوحى من
قانون روسيا مماثل يهدف الى قمع المعارضه
ويعيق تطلعات جوجل الانضمام الى النيتو
والاتحاد الاوروبي
[تصفيق]
قبل ان نستكمل ملف جورجيا والاحتاجات هناك
سنذهب الى زميلنا زياد حلبي ليطلعنا على
بعض التفاصيل الخاصه باطلاق النار في احد
المقاهي في تل ابيب زياد ما الجديد لديك
هذا صحيح عمليا ما حدث بان
منفذا فلسطينيا فتح النار على عدد من
الاسرائيليين بالقرب من مقهى على فكره على
بعد 200 متر فقط من حيث العمليه الاخيره
التي كانت في شارع ديزنجو في تل ابيب قبل
الشهور عمليا ما ادى الى اصابه ثلاثه على
الاقل من بينهم واحد في حال حرجه جدا لم
يعلن موته رسميا بعد
وهناك اصابه متوسطه الى خطيره واصابه
طفيفه جرى اطلاق النار على
المنفذ حالته حرجه هو ايضا جاء ذلك عمليا
يعني بعد بعيدا انتهاء المظاهرات في تل
ابيب كان هناك معلومات استخباراتيه في
الفتره الاخيره عن امكان ان يكون هناك
عمليات فرديه كهذه داخل الخط الاخضر داخل
المدن الاسرائيليه اذا اليوم هناك عمليه
جديده مسلحه في تل ابيب في شارع ديزنجو
فهو شارع عمليا رئيسي العصب الحياه
الرئيسي في مدينه تل ابيب بالنسبه
للاجراءات الامنيه هناك ماذا نعرف عنها
وهل عرفت هويه المنفذ ام لا
هذا في خلال ساعات يعني في خلال وقت قصير
سيعرف ولكن في البدايه كان هناك الكثير من
الارباك لدى الاسرائيليين لم يعرفوا في
البدايه ان كانت العمليه جنائيه او على
خلفيه سياسيه وامنيه كما تبين فيما بعد
وايضا اعتقدوا بان هناك اكثر من منفذ
ولهذا استنفرت قوات الشرطه وطلب من الناس
المكوث في البيوت لكن بعد ذلك تيقنوا من
ان هناك منفذا واحدا لهذه العمليه طبعا
الاجراءات الامنيه على قدم وساق في تلك
المنطقه جرى عزلها عمليا وتطويق المكان
واغلاق شارع بالكامل في الاستكمال
التحقيقات في فيما حدث
ورفعت حل الاستنفار في الشرطه اللافت طبعا
في الموضوع بان ذلك جاء بعد اقل من ساعتين
على عزل قائد لواء تل ابيب والوسط في
الشرطه الاسرائيليه من قبل وزير الامن
القومي بن جفير لانه لم راض عن درجه قمعه
للمحتجين اليوم في تل ابيب زياد ايضا نحن
نتحدث معك نتابع ايضا هذه الصوره يقال
بانها اخذت من احدى كاميرات المراقبه
لمنفذ هذه العمليه الى جانب بل بجانب هذا
المقهى في تل ابيب اذا الاعلام الاسرائيلي
ارسل صورا
لمنفذ العمليه يقال بانها اخذت من احدى
الكاميرات المراقبه على كل حال زياد شكرا
لك على كل هذه التفاصيل حتى الان بحال
ورود اي جديد سنعود اليك خلال هذه النشره
او النشرات اللاحقه شكرا لك زياد حلبي
سنعود مشاهدينا الان الى ملف جورجيا حيث
تتواصل الاحتجاجات هناك ياتي ذلك رغم ان
جورجيا هي اول دوله تعرضت للاجتياح الروسي
لكن يبدو ان الحكومه الحاليه في تبليسي
اقرب الى موسكو مما مضى فرغم ان جورجيا
اعلنت نيتها الانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي الا ان الحزب الحاكم هناك عمل
على تحسين علاقته بروسيا خلال الاعوام
الماضيه كما يرفض الافراج عن الرئيس
السابق ميخائيل سكتش بيلي المتهم في قضايا
فساد وهو حليف الدول الغربيه المفضل الذي
نظر اليه على انه واجهه للتصدي لنفوذ
روسيا في جمهوريات الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابقه
دعونا مشاهدينا نرجع الى الوراء قليلا
لبذور الازمه عام 2003 خرج الجورجيون
انذاك في تظاهرات لرفض النفوذ الروسي في
بلادهم نجحت الحركه والتي اطلق عليها ثوره
الورود وكانت واحده من سلسله حركات اطلقت
عليها بل اطلقت روسيا عليها اسم الثورات
الملونه التي تهدف لابعاد روسيا عن محيطها
السوفيتي انتهت الثوره بميخائيل سكتش بيلي
رئيسا لجورجيا واصبح عدو روسيا الاول
استمرت المناوشات بين روسيا وجورجيا حتى
عام 2008 حتى قررت موسكو اجتياحه جورجيا
من اجل حمايه القوميه الروسيه في منطقتين
داخل جورجيا كانت هذه اول حرب في اوروبا
في القرن الحادي والعشرين حينها اظهرت
روسيا قوتها العسكريه لاول مره خارج
حدودها منذ انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي وحققت
انتصار عسكريا واضحا
ما حدث في جورجيا يعتبر نسخه متطابقه
لازمه اخرى في جاره غير بعيده وهي شهيره
جدا الان اوكرانيا حيث ثوره اطلق عليها
اسم ثوره البرتقاليه ضد موسكو لكن روسيا
استعادت توازنها سريعا في اوكرانيا عن
طريق التحالف مع الرئيس فيكتوريا ثم بعد
ذلك قرر في 2013 تعليق اتفاقيه الشراكه
والتجاره مع الاتحاد الاوروبي في خطوه
راها المحتجون انها برعايه روسيا لتبدا
تظاهرات تحولت بعد ذلك الى اشتباكات
ورفوضى وانتهت في 2014 بفراري يانكووفيتش
الى روسيا ونجاح الجناح الاوكراني الذي
يميل الى الغرب
طبعا لم تنتهي الازمه عند هذا الحد فبدات
مرحله اخرى اجتاحت روسيا من طاقتها
وسيطرت على شبه جزيره القرب وكانت هذه
البدايه للحرب التي نشهدها حاليا لذا ما
تشهده جورجيا اليوم شهدته من قبل وشهدته
ايضا اوكرانيا ولكن التدخل العسكري
الروسيه يبدو مستبعدا جدا في الوقت الحالي
فموسكو الملهمكه في حرب اوكرانيا تنفي اي
صله لها بهذا القانون
[موسيقى]
من لها ينضم الى دكتور باسل الحاج جاسم
الباحث في العلاقات الروسيه الاوروبيه
والقوقاز دكتور باسل اهلا بك معنا اذا
اردنا ان نتابع ما يجري في جورجيا هل يجب
ان ننظر اليه بانه مشكله داخليه احتياجات
على قانون فقط امر اكبر من ذلك خاصه بانه
المحتجين حملوا خلال هذه الاحتجاجات على
بلادهم وعلم الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا هتفوا
لا لقانون روسيا
مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدين الكرام نحن امام
ازمه داخليه بابعاد اقليميه دوليه لها
جذور ولها اسباب ايضا
تجعل تداخل هذه العوامل الداخليه
والخارجيه
تنعكس على المشهد
ويجعلنا نقارنها كما جاء في المقدمه
والتقارير التي سبقت بانها مرتبطه
بالتطورات الاقليميه وعلى وجه الخصوص في
اوكرانيا طب يعني دكتور هل يمكن القول
باننا سنكون امام اوكرانيا ثانيه هل
سيتحول الامر الى ما جرى في اوكرانيا ام
من المستبعد ذلك اقله الان في هذا التوقيت
هنا يمكن القول ان اوكرانيا هي جورجيا
الثانيه
جورجيا بهذا السيناريو الان هناك قد يكون
او نكون امام بدايه لسيناريو مختلف معروف
ان
جورجيا بعد التجربه تجربه عام 2008 مع
روسيا وهي تجربه قاسيه دفعت ثمنها باهظا
انسلخ عنها اقليمين باتت روسيا تعترف
بانها دول مستقله الجنوبيه
وابغاديه لكنها على الرغم من كل ذلك تعمل
وتلتزم موقف حذر جدا حيال ما يجري في
اوكرانيا باسل اسمح لي ان اقاطعك لنذهب
الى امام مجلس النيابه في جورجيا لنتابع
ما يجري حيث ايضا هذه الاحتياجات ما زالت
مستمره وتجددت على الرغم من الوعود بسحب
هذا القانون سينضم الي من هناك الصحفي
اسلام شلبي اسلام اهلا بك معنا هل يمكن ان
تطلعنا على التطورات الحاصله هناك ماذا
يجري امام مجلس البرلمان هذه الاحتجاجات
هل تتطور كما حصل بالامس الى اشتباكات
الامور هادئه
اهلا بكم بالعربيه
لهذا المساء
اكيد الوطني الجردي كما تسمعون راعي
ضعف ذلك في الصباح الباكر كما قال رئيس
البرلمان الد
ف هذا مشروع هذا القانون من
جهه اليوم
[موسيقى]
الاول اعتقد ان الامور الليله طالما تم
سحب هذا القانون
بانه
هي وان كانوا في
المؤامرات الروسيه نظرا لان عليه
لانه قانون كبير يهدف الى قمع الحريات
بالنسبه للمحتاجين هل سيستمرون في هذه
الاحتياجات ايضا غدا
كما قالت القوى المعارضه ان الاحتجادات
مستمره رغم اعلان البرلمان انه في 12 ظهرا
من الخلف طاقه جلسه قارئه لسحب مشروع هذا
القانون تقول قوى المعارضه انه اذا لم يتم
ذلك في صباح الغد سيتم التظاهر مره اخرى
مجددا في المساء
شكرا لك من العاصمه تبليسي الصحفيه اسلام
شلبي على كل هذه المعلومات ما زلنا ايضا
نتابع هذه الصور من امام
البرلمان
جورجي هذه الاحتجاجات ما زالت مستمره كما
ذكر الان الصحفيه شلبي بانه الاحتجاجات
ستستمر حتى غد على الروم من اعلان
البرلمان بانه سيسحب هذا القانون
غدا الساعه الثانيه عشره طبعا بتوقيت
جورجيا ساذهب اليك مجددا دكتور باسل الحاج
جاسم الى اي حد تلعب الان الدوله الجورجيه
عمليه توازن بين مشاعر مواطنيها التي ترغب
بالانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا
موضوع الاهداف الجيو السياسيه لجارتها
روسيا
نحن الان امام موقفين الموقف الاول هو
للحزب الحاكم الحلم الجورجي وهو يتحدث ان
هذا القانون
يسير على غرار تشريع امريكي موجود منذ
الثلاثينيات في القرن الماضي وانهم
يحاولون الموازنه او المواضع موافقه بين
القيم التقليديه والسياده مع الولاء للقيم
الاوروبيه الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف شمال
الاطلسي بينما بالمقابل المعارضه ترى ان
هذا القانون يذكرها بقانون روسي مشابه قبل
عشر سنوات لكن الواضح اليوم ان الموقف
الجورجي الموقف الرسمي الذي يسير بحذر على
الرغم من دعمه اوكرانيا سياسيا دبلوماسيا
انسانيا
الا انه لم ينظم او يتعامل بحذر شديد مع
العقوبات الغربيه ضد روسيا لا يدعم عسكريا
اوكرانيا قد يكون هذا الموقف نعم فيه شيء
من الحساسيه للتحالف الغربي معروف انه بعد
ايام من بدء العمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا قبل قرابه عام في يوم واحد تقدمت
اوكرانيا و مولدافيا بطلب الانضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي الا اننا نجد اليوم
الموقف الرسمي لجورجا لا يتماشى مع كامل
الموقف الغربي شكرا لك اعذرني دكتور باسل
وانما انتهى وقت هذه المقابله دكتور باسل
الحاج جاسم الباحث في العلاقات الروسيه
الاوروبيه والقوقاز نشكرك على المشاركه
معنا في العربيات 360
[موسيقى]
حضرت الخارجيه الصينيه امريكا وحلفائها من
الاستمرار في عقليه الحرب البارده جاء ذلك
التعليقا على برنامج الغواصات النوويه
المشترك مع بريطانيا واستراليا
فيما يتعلق بالتعاون بين الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا واستراليا بشان الغواصه النوويه
فالصين اعلنت مرارا موقفها الرسمي نعتقد
ان التعاون بين دول الثلاث يشكل انتشارا
نوويا خطيرا ويؤثر على النظام الدولي في
سياسه عدم انتشار النووي ويحفز سباق
التسلح ويقوض السلامه والاستقرار في منطقه
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ كما ان هذا الامر
يقابل بمعارضه على نطاق واسع من قبل دول
المنطقه والمجتمع الدوليه نحث الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا واستراليا على التخلي
عن عقليه الحرب البارده والوفاء باخلاص
بالتزاماتها الدوليه وبذل المزيد للاسهام
في السلامه والاستقرار الدوليين
قبل ذلك كان الرئيس الصيني تشيم بينك دعا
الى الارتقاء بسرعه اكبر بالقوات المسلحه
وتحديثها الى مستوى عالمي وقال جيم بينك
في كلمه امام البرلمان انه يجب على الصين
تعظيم قدراتها الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه
وتحسين القوه الشامله للبلاد بشكل منهجي
للتعامل مع المخاطر الاستراتيجيه ياتي ذلك
بينما تواجه الصين عقوبات امريكيه في قطاع
الدفاعات العسكريه وهو الامر الذي يمنعها
من الحصول على تكنولوجيا متطوره
رغم العقوبات مشاهدينا يبدو ان الصين وجدت
طريقا للالتفاف على العقوبات الامريكيه
فالولايات المتحده فرضت عقوبات على بيع
اشباه الموصلات للصين الا ان الاخيره وجدت
طريقا للالتفاف على هذه العقوبات مجموعات
الذكاء الاصطناعي الصينيه وجدت الحال في
الخدمات السحابيه للتهرب من ضوابط تصدير
الرقائق الامريكيه فاين تايمز نشرت تقريرا
قالت فيه ان بعض الشركات الصينيه بدات
بتاجير الوصول الى رقائق انفيديا اي مئه
في هذه الحاله لا تحتاج الصين الى الشراء
جهاز الكمبيوتر لكنها ستستخدم جهازا ربما
في قاره اخرى عبر الانترنت يحتوي على هذه
الرقائق التي تحتاجها لتطوير برامجها
بالخطوه الالتفافيه هذه تتمكن الشركات
الصينيه من تطوير قدراتها في مجالات
الذكاء الاصطناعي مثل تقنيه التعرف على
الوجوه وغيرها دون فعليا على الرقائق
نقلت عن خبراء توقعاتهم بان الثغره هذه في
العقوبات ربما تدفع واشنطن لتشديد حصارها
على وصول التقنيه المتقدمه للصين
[موسيقى]
الجميع يعلم ان الصين التي تتحدى الولايات
المتحده بشكل متزايد في عده مجالات تظل
اولويتنا القصوى فالحزب الشيوعي الصيني
يواصل جهوده لتحقيق رؤيه الرئيس الصيني
لفرض الصين قوه بارزه في شرق اسيا وقوه
عظمى على المسرح العالمي على حساب القوه
والنفوذ الامريكيين وذلك عبر استخدام
ادوات حكوميه كامله منسقه لاجبار جيرانها
على الاذعان لمطالبها البريه والبحريه
والجويه بما فيها محاوله فرض سيادتها على
تايوان
ما تحدثنا عنه ليس طريقه الاحتيال الوحيده
للصين على العقوبات فنشرت شبكه فوكس نيوز
الامريكيه تقريرا يتهم الصين بسرقه اسرار
عسكريه امريكيه مهمه سرقه مكنتها على مر
السنوات من صناعه نسخه صينيه من المقاتله
الامريكيه اف 22
الاكثر تطورا في العالم
[موسيقى]
باقرار امريكي سقطت فخر الجويه الامريكيه
اف 22 عن عرش اقوى جيش في العالم فالتنين
الصيني تمكن من ضمها لاسطوله العسكري
بالسرقه وفقا لشبكه فوكس نيوز الامريكيه
تذكر الشبكه في لقاء اجرته مع جيمس
اندرسون القائم باعمال وكيلي وزاره الدفاع
السابق كيف صبت جهود تجسس الصين المستمره
منذ سنوات في صناعه جيل خامس من المقاتلات
الجويه مشروع بدات الصين عام 2008 ونجحت
في ادخاله الخدمه عام 2017 وفقا لمعلومات
سابقه كشفتها السوشيات غير ان السؤال الذي
يتبادر الى الاذهان هو كيف تمكنت الصين من
الحصول على معلومات شديده السريه
والحساسيه من داخل البرتغون
يجيب اندرسون ان الصين لجات اولا الى
الطرق الكلاسيكيه تجنيد واستماله متعاقدين
امريكيين واكاديميين وموظفين حكوميين
للحصول على بيانات اساسيه حول البرامج
والانظمه العسكريه ثانيا استخدام اساليب
اكثر تقدما مثل النشاط السيبراني لاختراق
قاعده بيانات وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
والاهم نشر اجهزه تجسس متطوره قادره على
جمع معلومات تمكنها من الحصول على الملفات
السريه وتحديد اماكن وجودها
لسنوات ظل دافع الصين لفهم المحركات
النفاثه الاكثر تطورا في الغرب حافزا
لمهمات تطوير عمليات التجسس لسد فجوه
عسكريه لطالما سعه واشنطن لابقائها ضمن
حدود تفوقها العسكري
اساليب التجسس الصينيه جعلتهم يقلصون فجوه
مدتها 30 عاما الى عشره اعوام فقط بيننا
وبينهم في تكنولوجيا المحركات النفاثه
ورغم تطابق الشكل الخارجي للمقاتله
الصينيه مع نظيرتها الامريكيه الا انه لا
يزال من الصعب تحديد مدى كفاءه جي 20
مقارنه باف 22 لكن استمرار تزايد التوتر
بين البلدين في ظل مناقشه غزو محتمل
لتايوان والذي قد يشمل ردا عسكريا امريكيا
سيكون ساحه مهمه لكشف حقيقه المقاتله
الصينيه بلا شك مكرم حناوي العربيه
الى واشنطن الان ومراسل العربيه بارغانم
بئر اهلا بك معنا هناك الان في الصين جيت
20 وهي تتطابق اقله حتى الان بالشكل لانه
لم يتم استخدامها لا نعرف اذا ايضا
بالمفعول كاف 22 هل هذا يؤكد بان مخاوف
الولايات المتحده من الصين
وقدراتها العسكريه في مكانه
الامريكيون منذ خمس سنوات وخصوصا خلال
الاشهر الماضيه
يشددون اكثر واكثر على الخطر الصيني لا
يسمون ذلك الخطر الصيني كلمه بكلمه ولكنهم
يعتبرون منذ فتره
ليست قليله ان الصين تكدس الكثير من
الاسلحه تقوم
بمحاوله بسط النفوذ في منطقه المحيط
الهادئ وتحاول ايضا ان تتجسس على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه حتى انها تخرق الانظمه
الامريكيه لدرجه انها تهدد الامن القومي
الامريكي يستعمل الامريكيون تعبير الخطر
المتلاحق او التحدي المتلاحق للصين
والمشكله الاكبر هو ان التفاهم بين
الدولتين شبه معدوم فالصينيون لا يتجاوبون
مع الامريكيين في قضايا اساسيه مثل الحد
من الاسلحه فتح الباب امام حوارات حول
الترسانه الصينيه ذكرت
التجسس اساليب التجسس تعددت بالنسبه للصين
يعني بدانا منذ سنوات مع هواوي وصلنا الى
المنطاد الان الى الرافعات تيك توك
هناك العديد من اساليب التجسس
لاستقاء المعلومات من الولايات المتحده
السؤال الان كيف يتم التعامل الامريكي مع
كل هذا التحدي الصيني
والجهات المعنيه بمكافحه التجسس تاكدوا
خلال الساعات الماضيه خلال شهادات امام
الكونجرس انهم يبذلون الكثير من الجهد
لمواجهه المحاولات الصينيه
لخرق الانظمه الامريكيه وتهديد الامن
القومي الامريكي
ولكنهم لا يفصلون ذلك لا ان هذه عمليات
مكافحه تجسس ولكن ما بدنا نشعر به حتى
الان هو امراني اساسيا الامر الاول هو ان
الشكوك لدى الامريكيين في اي شخص من
الممكن ان يتعامل مع الصين او لمصلحه
الصين اصبح مركز شبهه اكثر مما كان من قبل
المساله الثانيه المهمه ايضا بالنسبه الى
الامريكيين هو انهم وعوا الى ان هناك
خطوره في الاعتماد على الانتاج الصيني
ويعمل الامريكيون منذ فتره الرئيس السابق
دولار ترامب على انتاج الكثير من المواد
على الاراضي الام ريكيه بدلا من الصين
بايجاز لو سمحت اهميه التنسيق مع دول
الكويت لمواجهه التمدد الصيني
يعتبر الامريكيون ان هناك خطر محلق من قبل
الصين في تهديد امن الدول الجاره في هذه
المنطقه الرئيسه امريكي الحالي رفع مجموعه
الرباعيه او الكواد الى مستوى القمه
ويعتبر انها العمل مع اليابان واستراليا
والهند هو مساله جوهريه لمنع تمدد الصين
في منطقه المحيط الهادئ شكرا
دائما تسرينا بمعلوماتك وتوضيحاتك عما
يجري في الولايات المتحده وخاصه هذا
التصعيد مع الصين شكرا لك في ارغانم مراسل
العربيه من واشنطن
في العربيه 360 سنتابع بعد لحظات مصر تحذر
بانها لن تستكمل محادثات لا طائله منها مع
اثيوبيا بشان سد النهضه
[موسيقى]
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 هي من العاصمه
اليونانيه اثينا للتظاهرات المستمره لايام
ضد رئيس الوزراء كرياكوس التي تطالب
باقالته بعد حاجه اصطدام القطارين المميت
في البلاد
كان اعتذر عن الحادث وطلب العفو من اهالي
الضحايا الا ان المتظاهرين وصلوا الاحتجاج
ضده واصبح موقفه لاعاده انتخابه في يوليو
المقبل صعبا للغايه اما تصريح اليوم في
العربيه 360 لوزير الخارجيه المصري سامح
شكري الذي قال ان مصر ستدافع عن مصالح
شعبها اذا لم تراعي اثيوبيا حقوق دولتين
مصب بنهر النيل واضاف الشكر ان مصر لديها
شكوكا
شكوك حول وجود اراده سياسيه اثيوبيه
للتوصل للاتفاق بشان سد النهضه مضيفا انه
لا طائل من الاستمرار في مفاوضات دون
نتيجه
اما فيديو اليوم في العربيه 360 من مدينه
ميلان الايطاليه حيث قام ناشطون في مجال
البيئه برش الطلاء الاصفر على تمثال الملك
الايطالي السابق لتوليو ايمانويل الثاني
وذلك بحجه زياده الوعي حول المناخ واصبحت
هذه طريقه مالوفه لنشطاء البيئه من اجل
جذب الاهتمام في عدد من العواصم الاوروبيه
كثرنسا والمانيا فقبل اسبوع تم استهدافه
وزاره النقل الالمانيه بطلاء برتقالي وقبل
اشهر كان مقر الحكومه الفرنسيه هدف ايضا
[موسيقى]
الى هنا تنتهي العربيه 360 ولكن دائما
اخبار العربيه لا تنتهي فالان سننتقل الى
اخبار الساعه والزميل صهيب الشرير مجددا
معنا ماذا لديك في اخبار الساعه مساء
الخير مره اخرى ميسون خبر الساعه الاول
سيكون من تل ابيب سنتابع بعد قليل مع
مراسلنا ما اثرت عنه عمليه اطلاق النار
حتى الان الحصيله ثلاثه مصابين اسرائيليه
[موسيقى]